you know as everybody knows ladies um in
San Francisco known for so many things
but sometimes also it's about an hour
away from Napa Valley one of the world's
premier now I happen to enjoy a nice
glass of wine now and then so I couldn't
pass up the opportunity to check out the
Napa Valley for myself
I brought a camera crew with me this is
what happened in the northwest section
of Napa Valley and at the spring
mountain vineyard and as you can see
it's absolutely gorgeous here beautiful
and right here to talk to us Brian I
worked at Spring Mountain hi Brian how
are you I just saw Brian wandering
around the vineyard holding a half a
bottle of Sauvignon Blanc two glasses
and his pants were around his ankles
routinely have a drink at 8:30 in the
morning
as much as much as I can as often as I
can this is an intervention we're not
doing anything for the show well let's
try some shall we okay well why do you
do that cuz it's okay to spit by
spitting it out you can get the flavors
without the intoxication oh I'm sorry I
swallowed it
[Applause]
he said about spitting it out try it
again
try that again you guys swallowed it
[Applause]
yeah that was awesome
oh hi Connor you're Ron isn't Ron is the
vineyard manager is that correct that is
correct are you one of those guys that
can just lean down and taste the soil
and then find out if it's good yeah
really you ever tasted soil and you
could tell that Brian spit wine out
there like for you tell us about this
vehicle we'll be riding yeah this is a
1974 Pinzgauer it's a Swiss Army troop
transport why do you use a Swiss Army
troop transport six wheel drive it'll go
anywhere uh-huh and of course the Swiss
Army never gets into a fight so what do
they need their military vehicles good
question let's jump into space
[Music]
we came pretty much straight up the hill
now we're we're stuck and there's
nothing to do but Tehran's best of your
knowledge what happened here do you
think well I believe that I should keep
my talents in the vineyard and not
driving up in scour do you think you got
it so excited like oh my god this is
Conan O'Brien and you got really excited
and maybe yeah you you got caught up in
the celebrity is that what happens do
you need a drink see little shake is
yeah that's okay have a drink it's gonna
be fine we're gonna get the Pinzgauer
and if anything happens to this I
probably I'm sure the Swiss can send
over a swiss tractor okay well we got an
american-made caterpillar to pull us out
say hey you know what
USA USA right so here we are in the
vineyard on foot not part of the plan
but poor girl tell me a little bit this
is the vine these are the actual flower
clusters which turn into grapes after
they bloom and how do they turn into
grapes you're self pollinating so they
will self pollinating they are sounds
like me in college
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're in the wine cave here at Spring
Mountain now and this is Jack Jack Cole
Jake oh good to meet you you grow the
wine you grow the grapes you make the
wine and then you drink the wine and are
found crying in a field what we do know
these are of course I don't know the
terminology of I'm guessing this is a
barrels hole this is a big straw - big
straw
thank you looks like something I'm gonna
have to use when I'm 80 I'd like you to
leave now
so put it in the barrel okay look at
this you could have we got a place in
dirty music well I do
[Applause]
yeah so okay I just stuck the glass
shaft into the bunghole
yes unfortunately that's true okay you
know we're gonna read this transcript
back to you okay I'm now lifting oh look
at that look at that now what is it like
when you go to someone else's house
you're hanging out you having a good
time and they say Jack I can't have a
little wine are you oh this is not ready
and you should not serve this are you
controlling in those situations yes you
yes which is a good reason for why I'm
not invited to many kinds right right
that's why you live in a cave so this is
not Rhett this needs more time more time
time time is a big factor in the
equation of great wine incredible the
acoustics in here are fantastic yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the tasting room is that correct
tasting room all right if we are going
to do some tasting I need to make a
quick change excuse me please don't mind
thanks for waiting someone has brought
us what meat shopping in Guam lovely
crisp
wine from France and the Sun Sara and
let's taste it if you don't mind I
brought my own tasting glass is that
okay that would be
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you guys drinking
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]